on a tous l'espoir que d'ici 10 jours
les doses restantes à régler et que la
vaccination de voter donc on ne peut
qu'adhérer évidemment c'est le dernier à
mourir malek parce qu'il nous a rejoint
en l'appelant entendu je veux juste
faire un petit complément en rejoignant
ont dit oui à rimou j'ai répondu oui
auto test mais pas test salivaire les
autotests ne sont pas encore lancé des
tests salivaires sont lancés à l'école
importe on fait les laisse aller mais ce
n'est pas la même chose en tout cas
d'orange free mais il est ce que je vais
dire c'est qu'on fait des tests à
l'essai ce que ce soit ce test ou pas on
fait des tests à l'école je vois juste
est ce le débat de ce soir et on en
n'est que l'illustration qu'on est en
train d'assister à un sketch en fait
depuis des mois
moi la première vague je voulais pas
tomber sur le gouvernement parce que ça
nous est tous tombés dessus
mais le souci c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
ait un an après qu'on n'a pas appris des
leçons du passé
depuis le début c'est une blague tester
isolé protéger ça n'a jamais marché
les frontières on a mis du temps à
contrôler saga des gens qui sont rentrés
en étant positif on n'a aucune stratégie
de dépistage sur ce territoire là il ya
deux personnes deux atsem qui bossent
ensemble une a été testée bi foua
l'autre n'a jamais fait de test pcr
c'est un problème et ça c'est une
réalité en stratégie d'isolement c'est
aussi un échec
aujourd'hui des salariés qui partent
bosser en étant positif parce qu'ils ont
la pression de l'employeur
c'est une réalité donc la faute du
gouvernement mais c'est aussi un check
sur l'annoncé du bon sens des gens
apprécient aussi un échec sur la streif
gouvernement à s'exprimer sur ce plateau
en janvier on a reçu des médecins quand
on parlait déjà de confinement qui nous
parle de l'arrivé des variants de la
présence des variantes de leur
dangerosité
et il nous parlait déjà de cette
perspective de mi mars on y est ils ne
se sont pas trompés il en a fait le
président à l'époque il a fait un pari
le pari de ne par confiner au red star
vie qu'il a fait mais là on est une
femme
c'était malade n'a pas il a laissé
parler tout le monde il a entièrement
raison
le pâté c'est un échec il a fait le pari
de pâques c'est aujourd'hui ces
décisions politiques en même temps sur
les écoles c'est aussi un échec on ne
veut pas fermer les gens de laisser le
petit trophée aux soldats blancs caire
mais c'est une faute n'a aujourd'hui
dans les écoles pour j'ai eu une chef
d'établissement d'un lycée dans le val
d'oise le val d'oise et 500 mousser les
deux départements d'île de france où le
virus circule le plus elle m'a dit mon
boulot depuis deux semaines c'est de
rappeler qu'à contacter cas positifs les
prévenir les parents elle ne fait plus
que ça les parents ne sont plus dans
l'instruction leur boulot c'est de
veiller au respect du protocole
sanitaire veiller à ce que tout le monde
respecte le geste et ça c'est pas leur
boulot
plus personne s'en sorte qu'ils existent
pourquoi la faire votre choix pourquoi
la faire nôtre sur moi je soutiens ce
sont deux je pars pas de fermeture mais
c'est la seule à la proposition de
valérie pécresse tout va me tomber
dessus en disant oui mais t'es pas de
son bord politique mais tu vas le tombé
dessus mais sans chose tout de même
vendu mon sens tout à l'heure on a parlé
d' anticipation le président en parler
et c'est ça en fait depuis le début on
est que dans la réaction et pas dans la
prévention
[ __ ] désolé je suis vulgaire fouet un
moment un an après votre ip un an après
anticipons et réduisons médias des
viandes ont rapidement finir il ya des
gamins aujourd'hui en sport qui sont
sans masquer les brassages dans les
couloirs c'est n'importe quoi
aujourd'hui dans les listes dans les
établissements scolaires il ya du
personnel des surveillants des
personnels de cantine qui sont positifs
qui parle bosser c'est un enfer coupons
disons juste pause pendant deux semaines
et arrêtons et je veux juste lâché un
petit mot pour tous les étudiants bts
qui sont dans les lycées dont on ne
parle pas je reçois des centaines et des
centaines de témoignages
allez voir sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
accablant on parle des étudiants dans
les universités on ne parle pas des
étudiants en bts ils vivent une
situation qui est affreuse ils sont en
paix sa entassés pas en demi groupe
contrairement aux lycéens mais dans des
classes entières dans des salles
entières